reject Nation if there were a hall of fame for
Digital entertainment I'd be its proud curator
introducing you to the P g2a gate 2 Adventure
believe me it's the adventure terminal that
even Legends speak of so what's GTA secret sauce
imagine a world where Netflix marathons swiping
right on Tinder epic game showdowns and even
that Amazon shopping spree all converge and hey
if you're thinking software GTA is got that
digital magic too but wait there's more the
prices are so slashed they'd make a discount store
plush and the instant delivery faster than a wink
from yours truly now brace yourselves cuz g2a is
pulling all stops for their birthday bash if your
basket in the USA Sunshine gaming laptops in an
entire year of free games backing you it's almost
as good as a day in my Entourage I definitely have
friends in summary dive head first into g2a gate
2 Adventure bask in digital Glory grab those
deals and remember if it's on g2a it's bound
to be legendary much like some people we know wink
I definitely have a friend citizens of the reject
nation is time for Loki season 2 episode thr today
jge how are you doing I'm ready for moas all right
Koy how you do lowkey excited lowkey oh yeah
that's you really demonstrated that with your 10
a Mobius pun I felt pressure ladies and gentlemen
you know what to do prune that like button or no
don't take it away that'd be terrible and uh
subscribe click the notification Bell to get
if I want to reaction for the next episode is up
here on this Chanel as always full length Reaction
watch along so you sync up with your own copy
of Loki available for super sexy Rejects at our
patreon page thank you to all who have joined
already becoming super sexy Rejects and over
there we cover several things exclusively with
highlights and watch alongs included let's explore
the Multiverse containment doors are locked and
only the person who designed it can open it with
a Liv scan of his temporal Aura they're going to
need to get Victor timely for that maybe Victor
timley is an evil cuz he hasn't developed it yet
I don't think he's going to be evil think he's
going to be a guy I think he's going to have
good intentions he's going to be like uh miles
Dyson I think you're right feels Victor
timely I mean yeah feels like it's from
that era I hope he's playing jazzy good
time perfect rendition I love it I never
thought we'd hear this rag Time marel
theme who's that guy who does the grop
cheese or whatever Richard Cheese Rich
Che this is delightful new ringtone rag
time Marvel Suite here for it that Rona
yep where is she she are you looking for
you what took you so long seems so obvious
what am I doing here I'll don't get your
bridges in a stir that depth play with the
stairs is great first things first do you
have it it always looks like she's standing
on something yeah the dep of the stairs was
so clever the mcness of it all we need to put
this package in that window it was his plan
meant to protect all of time she's so much
more sassy now he's dead what this was the
plan he made when he knew the end was near for
him oh man he didn't watch this utter chaos he
had a plan okay who would better yep totally
blending in Steamboat Miss minutes when he's
back where he belongs you and I will be right
by his side polyamorous relationship oh my God
lot of hands on that clock is that the young
version of him Victor childly oh what's in the
book hope this child knows how to read how common
was reading in the 1860s how literate were we as
a country did audible existed yet could I listen
to this book Nick Offman Nar T handbook yes yes
amazing oh my God so if the timeline Works where
if you learn something you remember it how much
do throwing off the sacred timeline work if he's
delivering knowledge that doesn't yet exist we
can't get in there and increase the diameter
of the Looms intake ring include that knot of
unrefined time wait a second wait a second uh
in English please we need to scale the lom's
capacity to manage all those new branches a thank
God he spoken English we can hack into the system
really oh that is such a relief I'm wondering
tap it in the main frame OB what about Miss
minutes how are we going to find a little rogue
cartoon clock that doesn't want to be found love
these slow zooms are back it's like a monster
approaching we know Miss minut sent information
to rer and then we never saw her again the two
hits we had on the temp pad Trace it's like a
submarine movie but entire yeah good call let's
focus on that cartoon clock they didn't call her
a cartoon before okay we got a hit on the temp
pad going from right here Chicago 1868 to the
same spot Shanghai Noon I go that way you go this
way I mean this isn't a pivot point in history any
major figure rises from here like I always got a
green tie on let's go to 93 Ramona what are you up
to I like how his mustache fits in this
timeline very well a zoom and a track
cool what a transition that was beautiful this
is the outfits they wore when they saw Victor
timley Edison HH Holmes yes air balloons HH
holes accomplished murderer if she has Mis
minutes there to help her there's definitely
a purpose for them going there earlier but we
just got to figure it out it really hired
all these extras Liberty building debut
on 4th of July ghost clock I love how Mobius
is actually in costumes this time let me see
that the name's chaplain charie chap just that of
sh I never got your name name's chaplain Charlie
chap Miss minutes is right there ghost clock
continues to haunt Midway right exactly that's
affecting the sacred time right yes get a little
Irish cloth Chinese Pavilion cool brief detail for
Refreshments yes yeah the crackerjack concession
stand there's a hi traffic area it was necessary
and logical we get is the sightseeing I'm not
sightseeing listen we have different styles
he actually gets to explore this time I take a
more slow deliberate cerebral approach because
I see everything I Noti this everything I
love how Mobius is actually becoming Owen
Wilson I know all we need is an ohow wow
oh man oh oh you make your little homesick
it's completely inaccurate somebody feeling
a little left out that they're not up there
no why they include Boulder not even heard of
him they got Boulder bre you know sometimes I
forget that you're one of them you are one of
them one of us offs my mind [Music] H wasn't
that might SL Victor fin oh temporal Marvels
it's probably must be really connecting to
the Marvels you think it's the second time
they brought that word up this is [Music] it
no the game is a foot this feels like a western
Showdown [Music] what fun costumes and hair and
makeup really brought this to life there
she is it's so expensive it is expensive
yeah they should have just cged everyone I
mean yeah the volume's right there scan all
those extras is there not an AI they could use
oh my God the scene the scene is that balloon
I think so time oh every it moves through
each and every one of us he's a showman it
shapes Our Lives how is in the shadows our
futures such Tom Hardy energy we can shape
it it's him who he remains ladies
[Music] and sound like this terrifying
figure can I tell you that that
plays so much better to me yeah
it really works just what would you
know about the future boy oh oh boy
and the answer is more than you might think
good pause there look where we are I me to
see guys trying to pention to the show energy
of the past present and future flows oh around
us temporal loon the electricity flowing through
it Gathering it into fine threads of time power
power which it then we Le okay ropes of voltage
interesting in English please a chaos a chaos
transformed into order nice single B can light
genius the whole of Chicago he's like the Tesla
it's such a different performance but so
similar to human genius the Showmanship
now makes a little bit more sense too I aim
to power the entire planet call it a dream F
laugh it off as pure science fiction I love how
this is always from the audience's seat where
you're seeing him yeah our ey line all science
is fixing until it going to Blind him with
science welcome wow welcome
to is like wow wow you're so
dominant you need to bring him back to
the TVA yeah you can't trust a variant
of he who remains in the TVA that's a later
problem we have a very serious now problem
they're doing it yep he just described how
to solve it is the only thing that can get
us access to the loom and who knows what else
he can do just cut off one of his hands and
take it there I must have your temple Loom
step aside horn swagler I was here first oh
$1,000 that look I believe we have a a
deal wowe don't get mugged that is the man
who's destined to become he who remains
you sure your plan is going to work the
machine's not going to turn on again God
B hey I show you any physical contact was
purely incidental interesting how about
we settle this outside let's go Lincoln
I agree wow the amazing Loki everyone I
need to talk with you about something yes
my future you walk and Tim oh my excuse
me my and I would love to tell you about a little
business I beg your pardon fellas you know who
this is you all know each other unfortunately your
old friend colle long time remember everyone just
touching you you're a confidence trickster
luminary is the word you're looking for a
disruptor cruel technology of this era to catch
up with my Visionary mind you know I never doubted
it for a second enlightened fellows never do
your inventions are fake oh no excuse me oh
boy Huer Timely I'm oh the pyramids this is
where it becomes [Music] Ramen there he is go
hiding behind one little pole there's
no escape from this Sky f a thief in
here smart to do some of this in
unbroken shots all right look CLE
you're really good at getting away we have
that in still me oh sh ah you stay out of
this just wait but when is she from remember show
had the temp pad thing in the last episode yeah
but I'm wondering what is this directly after
that event we don't work together anymore movus
I don't have to tell you anything it look we're
not working together scotcha you're a fugitive
in all of time what is going on we need him
without his help the TVA will be destroyed
good Let It Burn maybe this is all part of
the plan damn yeah I'm really paranoid time
VAR I know there won't be a life to go back
to and we can't fix it without him I really
do wonder if he who remains this is part of his
domino effect yeah we need your help no obious
there is no we not anymore for no time never
imagine if this had come out before Ant-Man
H temporarily not canon Antman oh no o where
do you think he got that book if you in the
TVA hadn't messed with him oh you're smart oh
you're so smart Slayer set him on a path that
he wasn't meant for you are waling him straight
back into the TVA damn you figured that all out
I didn't give him this book I was shocked when
I saw his face too maybe we should throw him off
this feris wheel but we need him he just like a
d I love this music you haven't got a clue have
you what a beautiful cloth set but of the
time he may be our best hope of saving them
mean our Mis Min this is very familiar
isn't it I Can't Let Him Live kill him
right after he fixes the Miss I you
know I I might be on sylv's side on
this way oh my God I feel like sylv's
right but everyone dies I really feel
like this is all part of he who remains big
plan this is your moment get him moment W
boo stay puffed minutes so questions
wow wow t on bicycle absolutely not
adorable come on we need it it's
almost a jet ski you'll love this
make yourself comfortable this is
where she falls in love with him um
so oh oh my God she is Charmed by
him already yeah it's working but
here controls the temperature through the
cushion it's got a butt warmer oh and a
butt Chiller he invented The Sharper Image
so did you like my performance back there
oo marvelous a bit creepy thank
you marvelous Miss men excuse
Melle minutes so odd absolutely
singular well thank you you're
pretty singular yourself at least you
will be are you saying I created the
TVA I know this must be overwhelming I'm
going to be rich it's like the story of my
of my myself always imagined is is true did you
hear the murder part that is why you need me by
your side such intimacy I'll keep you safe even
before the TVA or her you created me and we work
together at the end of time I know what a great
man you can become mm love him too I think so
weirdest love triangle ever arloom it's in
trouble that is not dissimilar to what the
wizard gentleman said to me on the ferris wheel
why AR the two of you in cahoots with him and his
Butler time to go in a timely fashion
I do think Jonathan Major's childish
Wonder to all this is really interesting stuff for
Victor timley and his same work with
dvon is really good too he's mine r b
oh Jacob she's out [Music] yours they're
having so much fun with the music anything
nothing okay I'll have B15 Runner trace this
way go stranger weirder season and shot so much
darker I love that he has like a a Panic Room
I do like this reintroduction of Victor timley
of a good in attention man like he's not
cunning or evil I mean you see yeah but
he's not villainous what's this latest work
of yours it's so important she's playing as
the Moonlight beautiful key to understanding
and manipulating type everything I've ever
imagined or that were imagined for me she seems
so enamored by him it was delivered to me and
I have a child she might have loved the concept
of him before and then met him or maybe an older
version of herself is getting some Nostalgia
subconscious feeling I've never found out
who you I brought it to you you brought it to him
the way the postman brings the
post we both know whose plan it
was well whoever it was I thank you and I
hope they remain that I may thank them too
I like to think of it as a correspondence
between myself and the Visionary very auor
I always knew my ideas were good didn't have
the technology to make them really work I'm
rooting for you man I know that's how you make K
captivating you have variance that like multiple
facets thank you and what an actor's
dream to get to play so many versions
and to continue to do so indefinitely
starting to see the manual become grab
it yes appreciate that this Min looks
so peeed I have high hopes for this
partnership I could rule [Music]
together o he doesn't want a part he doesn't
like partn said it earlier it was all good
till you said that [__] get on my boat
whoa W that was a sweet shot nicely done
oh wow you heard her Victor partnership you had
to do it oh bye miss m there's that villainous
side H wow what an impulsive decision Rona
that's so messed up it really is I was like
dude just one come on all that find out
you were you are who you are because she
dropped off the book to you just like should
have said that word no don't like my partner
does capture that ego and stubbornness though I
have a um seat float a float don't worry about
me yeah you can already see like
the the sketch of the TVA in here
look at all your amazing work I'm
so happy to be here really laying
on the sultry tone just wonderful yes
you have always been so smart Victor
is now what's the rush T's having so much fun
with this it might be smart to lay low for a
while we made quite the Ruckus back there what
is she trying to seduce feels like I was worried
that you wouldn't come with me that you liked
raona better than me oh my god oh yeah is there a
sketch of made in that journal yours draw me like
one of your French girls when you first created
me I was just a simple AI just something to play
chess with I love that they're doing this I could
be more for you so you gave me autonomy to write
my own programming Disney's her I was allowed to
have wants and follow whims and become who I am
you're the Creator each night we play Jess and
talk a loyal friend more than friends oh there
was one one whim you never allowed me pleasure
why didn't you allow me a real body yes yes if I
had a body we could truly lead together oh my God
no partnership like the evil version of vision I
don't know how to to do you never even tried just
standing in midst a bunch of man bodies it's like
Bride of Frankenstein wanting to become the bride
yeah instead of what I could have been your girl
yikes I love this so much so glad they're doing
this put that down don't do this for you need me
I love you wow whoa It's like some weird Black
Mirror [__] yeah they better do it lovers Tiff
oh thank God yeah buddy things are getting quite
straight you going to prune my boot my dude
oh my God the early days of pruning I was
entrusted with this Mission by he who remains
not his variant I'm the one in charge I am the
captain now miss R slay off what are you doing I
mean is this the Free Will that you were looking
for that is what she said at the end of last
EP last season I'm not leur I'm bading after
all those years of doing your dirty work this
guy's always caught in a hostage situation he
just met all these people we've all lost our
way but someone has to keep track of the big
picture here Loki holding power I'm the only
one who can bring stability to the TVA because
that's what I've been doing thanklessly for
eons wow you were dry away so you star off a
correlation order versus chaos W I'm order is she
going to PR him let's get fascist oh I'm [Music]
chaos wow this is like a Terminator
2 situation yeah it is like miles
Dyson she's like Sarah Cotter she
hunting him through time I haven't
done anything no you will you will
that that isn't me you don't know
me you don't know the heart the heart I
I have beating in my chest Jesus this is
compelling I can make my own choices Branch the to
technically can I'm not the man you
think I am free will fate her whole
[Music] thing get him out of here oh yeah
oh my God they're bringing him to the TVA
this is crazy what a crazy plot turn God I
mean that's what I thought would happen but
still cool it's happening yeah don't make me
regret this we'll do our best and you leave
her to me yeah fight fight fight I suppose
I've been a box you've been wanting to take
for a long time oof no that's painful I've
killed you a thousand times in my mind each
time more brutal than the last it's crippling
that kind of obsession have you called him sick
to McDonald's you're going to get fired you
were working the next day you said so it's
power for you isn't it be careful what you
wish for oh he still W put in the void oh
damn nice oh oh oh my God how Bleak
together forever that's great form of
punishment right right there wow get to
be with your ba away from that canivan
clock that is [Music] great how poetic
love it love you oh darn darn foolish
of him to make an enemy out of someone
who knows all his Secrets really big one
about you uhhuh I can tell you but who's
watching this it's going to make you real
Angry no no no oh my goodness oh my goodness
well well well all right ladies and gentlemen
um listening to this on Apple and spot 5 we just
watched Loki season 2 episode th be sure to rate
this we will talk about it but before we do thank
you to everyone who is M www.re Nation shop we're
all wearing shirts available at that store right
now Coy's got a real reject t on I got a purp
Watchman inspired who influences the influencers
John's got the citizen King one on and we got a
whole bunch of other te's as well it is an amazing
Immaculate way to support the Channel show you a
citizen of the reject nation and the most proper
way look good while doing it thank you guys so
much means a lot for everyone who's uh picked up
a tea really really because creatively involved
in it so means a lot anyway um who rated first
last time would you rate this uh I'm going to
go since I know we use decimals now uh 8.9 okay
I'm going to give this an 11.1 all right uh LED
it i' I'd actually meet you at exactly an 8.0 D
youc yeah all right Co you can go first okay um
I I feel like this was what I wanted the second
episode to be I also feel like this is exactly
what I wanted gang to be I'm a little I'm kind of
struggling with Ant-Man existing in my head right
now because I I know uh ant I like ants uh but I
know it's going to upset people that enjoy Ant-Man
and you please enjoy what youy that defense is
all over Twitter now all people are like Ant-Man
fa life you guys don't get it and that's what it
is it's full of he didn't actually get taken out
by don't you see fought SK no I he was weakened
by but a man that is the coner of time was even
affected by ants so we didn't get killed affected
by ants ants who advanced their their civilization
thousands of years off screen off screen I
like ants okay Honey I Shrunk the kid should
not have as much Vin diagram and taken out Kang as
anyway anyway I think that in my head Cannon the
Ant-Man timeline has been pruned and this is now
what follows Loki season 1 in any way of having
Kang the beauty of Kang is it is the actor's
dream role it is a a villain that is the visual
representation of duplicities it is someone whose
Duality is every bit of the character as well as
time it is the use of time and space it is the
use of an actor playing someone with that much
multiversal and and internal conflict and I think
that Jonathan maor is one of the great actors of
our time uh and there was definitely some Bronson
Tom Hardy that I enjoyed in that stage performance
but he played he who remains in a similar way to
Victor timley that was completely theatrical but
in in a time period it worked and then Kang was
differently theatrical but in a somber way because
he was a Kang that had been trapped and those
three performances are just the beginning of
what Kang can be in shape out personally I didn't
love the writing of how they had K but I did enjoy
what majors brought to the performance of the now
not head can and Ant-Man movie I do think however
this delivery allows for there to be the Kang
Dynasty's impact of having a a series of kangs
that you can feel for against and for because now
that Kang can do horrible things and we've met
Victor timley who does have that childlike wonder
and innocence who does have that impact of someone
you can see what they just wanted to do but still
can do evil things like just disavow someone who
literally caused their success someone that is
able to be Tesla but also Edison um so I loved
that element but I did struggle a little bit with
the um the reason it's not a nine or higher is the
tone um there were moments that felt uh a bit
disi um there were moments that were like let's
make sure this is also High jinxy fun because of
the dark tone there were a couple moments that did
feel like it was a borderline slap stick that if
this was a slapstick show would have fit but there
is a there's a difference between mischievous and
playful which I think that both Heston Wilson and
uh Majors do well but then you have the directing
and the editing like have like and it almost got
to like where I was expecting them to run in
circles and play like old British music like
it it it got a little much Hill in there yeah
thank you that was what I was looking for uh it
didn't quite mesh with the rest so it can't be
a nine because that's approaching perfect but
all the story advance all the exposition all
the performances all the delivery all of the
fixes that I had issues with episode 2 were here
I just had some tone stuff yeah I think I I know
what you're talking about because I think the
intention is very clear of wanting to emulate
period pieces older like so much of as compared
to season 1 there's a lot of cinematic influences
of other eras in this season and I I think Theo
choice and the intention is very obvious that they
wanted to emulate kind of what you know those
those old timey uh kind of uh humorous angles
would happen and with that kind of quirkiness
and stuff and intent is one thing and overall
um execution is another hunt for out October
worked that didn't like you know what I mean
that scene felt like a submovie but we didn't go
oh that's distracting like this was a little much
yeah that I I understand what they were going for
uh with that Whimsy but at times for just for my
taste yeah it wasn't quite meshing for me either
um it didn't quite tickle me in the way I think
it it wanted to but damn a B minus B+ a minus like
I I want the positives to shine because I I agree
and I think this was a leap back from episode
one like one was like that 98 two dropped for
me this is back yeah and I I love what they're
doing because you know when you first say that
King is going to be your big baddy for going into
the next couple phases of Marvel you kind of have
this preconceived idea of just another like oh big
threat yeah big threat and you're starting to get
a bigger you're trying to get a better impression
of of what it is of watching the creation of
something like there's I like the I like the
tangibility of hope that oh maybe there's a way
we can prevent it yeah what if free will like you
know you're having that moment with Victor timley
at the end I'm like that's not like this is this
is the he's not Nathaniel Richards but he is the
Kang of of our of the Sacred timeline like there
maybe there's a hope here of maybe we can use this
guy maybe to fight the other versions you know
yeah like there maybe there's a chance we could
learn from him maybe he won't turn bad but you
really don't know you really don't know because
at the end of the day like that's why I love the
decision that they made where he does drop raona
into the water because you're like but there's
that there's a bad guy in him there's still a
v there's still a narcissist in this dude there's
still a villain within him like can we trust him
and that's that paranoia that I love because they
set up at the very beginning too Miss minut saying
that there's this like I don't forget who exactly
essentially there's like a contingency plan that
if he who remains were to die here's what he
would want to happen which is again the the
Gess of of uh the deceit of um of of of he who
remains where he presented to Loki and Sylvie
that kill me you rule you can rule this it all
all could be chaos or you know uh but he had a
plan in mind the whole time in case so I'm like
are we just watching his plan play out right now
if he hadn't been killed would he have gotten on
the sacred timeline that book like that element
yeah that's what I mean it's like he he he's
still playing some domino effect in a way of
possibly Conjuring up some resurrection of himself
yeah you know and I think it's brilliant it's it
because I you don't you just don't know you have
no idea and even though some of that quirkiness
so what they were attempting to emulate was not
really driving with me I love when they do decide
to go stranger with it like everything with Miss
minutes her weird obsession with wanting to become
like human anatomy I love it absolutely love it
because it is uncomfortable it's um it's sexual in
a way without being uh you know graphic but it's
still like strange and unsettling yeah because
she want she wants him ter strong killing it too
like that performance was all her I love it I love
it so much sexy disembodied clock yeah I think
that's great I do have and and I love like Loki
and and Mobius uh them bonding together everything
that like I love the different shades we getting
amobia we didn't get the bike I wanted the bike
bike sorry um end of the season and again yeah
again the set pieces are are absolutely awesome
and ravona I think I think ra like what's like you
know you're talking about like duality of things
with ravona and MOB oh man that ended with Rono so
much happened in this episode with like Rona
obviously doesn't want everything to collaps
either she doesn't want the the ex existence to
come to an end so there is paths that they have
goals that they have that are similar but yet
so different at the same time and and um I think
my one thing that that I am wondering about the
show if it's still gonna if it's going to bother
me it's might sound odd it's Loki Loki kind of
just seems like a TVA agent with superpowers now
I think that's why they gave him Powers is like
give him stuff to do and I'm missing a little
bit of his personality of his personal Journey
that might have also why they let the Brad scene
play the personal Journey the personality it's
it's some of that is not seeming as much of a
it's called Loki at the end of the day yeah and
and at the same time like I get he went through
a character Arc uh but there does seem to be
something like Tom H it's weird it's the the
complexity of I think Tom Hon's killing it and
anchors it with what he's what he's giving yeah
but it is just so straight forward with him and
I am missing I I I'm kind of like everyone else
is like seems like they're getting such great
development which is awesome like I love that
I just wish it was also in conjunction with Loki
like the season twos are often that right where at
season one you have your character season two
you build the sporting but then at the end of
season you well yeah but nothing's perfect except
but then at the end of season two you see the arc
that's been the slowburn like like the Bear right
like the have you seen the bear no okay well the
bear is a great example I've Seen Better Call
Saul Breaking Bad those you know excuse me for
Citizen Kane over here I'm sorry I'm sorry good
Fellas and The Godfather were taking there are
shows youate that you you would very much enjoy it
as a creative person of all Stripes you would love
it and that does it John knows what I'm saying
the second season how they do that thing where
the whole rest of the cast you think is rising and
then at the end you realize that their Rising has
caused the shift in the lead and you go oh the at
the end of the second season is now was about all
of them not just the support so they do that I
just rewatched it that's that's in my mind but
I think the show was going to do that where Tom
Hon's Arc is going to really shine episodes four
five and six okay that's my hope because right
now it has just been very um that that is that
is the one thing that is like kind of missing for
me well he hasn't not been there like the scene in
the pie place we we talked about the reversal
we talked about like the scene with Brad like
there have been elements but I do see where we're
talking about everyone but him you're not wrong
yeah we're we're not talking about and like it's
Tom hson he's a force like it's not him it's just
whatever everyone else is also having to do yeah
yeah everyone else has the much more interesting
stuff happen and he's just kind of the plot device
to keep things going along yeah and and that is a
that that's something that I am correct but sorry
John I kind of just derailed this no it's okay
I mean your points my Ral rating was what 11.1
and you said that that brought me down to like a
10.8 and then what you just said brought me down
to like a 10.2 you know so like I mean yeah no
everything you guys are are saying I I I at least
I'm not affected the same way by all these things
but I do acknowledge that they're there like yeah
especially in the middle of the episode with all
the different guys chasing timely around who've
all been bamboozled like it's very of the time
but it is like an interlude you don't necessarily
need but that adds you know just like extra kind
of chaos to everything I was fine with that but
yeah I I get why maybe that would be something
where you're like ah can we get back to the
point because just turn the music down sure
and and with Loki certainly this is the episode
where of the three it feels the least centered
around his actual character so much as you know
there's more interesting stuff for yeah the The
Supporting Cast to do learn experience Etc uh so
in light of that I would put the first episode
at the top because it's all these things it's the
weird it's the Intrigue it's lowkey and then the
second episode I would rank third so far because
it's still like lowkey and it's still about the
relationships and and his tension with Sylvia and
all that and this is very much like a functional
episode for him but what I thought this really
did nicely was like I forgot about time while
I was watching this this felt like a substantial
little movie of an episode and I thought it really
well committed to its time and place and used
it richly whereas last episode I was like ah
it feels like some of these things could have
been utilized and explored more richly this is
like no we did our you know 19th century Chicago
episode they understood the importance of this
episode that's a great point I didn't feel like
we cared about the 80s uh and that would have been
fun like an ' 80s actor episode and then and then
an 1800 Chicago episode you're right the setting
here was great yeah and it's like it it it uses
this sort of World's Fair aesthetic and it uses
the Tesla you know Edison like all those trappings
that are fun and are of the time the genre of the
place are really well utilized here and everything
kind of seemed to serve some level of purpose and
so even having all those hyinks I was like well
that's adding at least to a Chase that's already
ensuing between all the main characters too um
and yeah I love that they decided and found time
and means within an episode like this that is
again getting back to the main villain uh they
they just found time for so many great debates
and questions and that's not something I'm as
used to in a Marvel uh and that I thought was
lovely here because obviously the the most rich
one is I loved Sylvie facing down with him sword
to his neck and him being like I I haven't made
these choices like throwing her argument back
at her and I thought this episode was a great
sort of catapulting of different arguments back
and forth you've got ravona and Mobius kind of
going in a similar Direction but for entirely
different motivations and I thought that was
really tangible and lovely and like her presence
I thought even though she is you know amidst all
this chaos I think uh it's gooo and baar ra right
like she's got a lovely presence even still and
I'm still interested in seeing her and how that
continues and even what her weird relationship
with Miss m is now that Miss Min clearly has her
own motivation and that was a thing where I'm like
we don't have to do this and it's Disney it's kind
of a weird thing to be doing but I'm glad we're
doing it because it's all part of the possibility
of this strange little world and uh and and yeah I
thought this was a well proportioned episode and
I thought it did all the all the things I love
from sci-fi kind of in one big pot you know it's
got sci-fi fun and games but it's got a lot of
like weird uncomfortable situations that that now
we get to think about because of these extraneous
circumstances and it's also got the personal stuff
the heft of the journey for somebody like Sylvie
but also like the real question of like yeah
it seems like we're backed into a corner where
the only solution is either bring Victor timely
back or somehow strong our Mis minutes into doing
this and so either way we're in kind of a bad
position here so you know we got to choose the
lesser of two evils and yeah I don't know I just
thought all of that was really acious and really
you know easy to get swept up in and yeah it was
fun in games but also like nice and cerebral and
odd and emotional too so I'm I'm gonna go back to
I'm gonna go to r nine you just you tip me up one
that that point one I'm at I'm at 90 now because
of the setting Point that's a really good point
so yeah I think this was exceptional like this was
it's not quite the perfect near perfect I thought
the first was but this was really good like this
feels like what I wanted lowkey season 2 to be
when season one ended like this using time using
space using Kang building out phase I would have
thought of this as phase four before they I think
early ended phase four but this this phase four
time and space continuum situation and it does
feel like it's going to lead nicely to what I
assume Deadpool 3 and King Dynasty are um ravona
was in in that recording in that first episode
ravona sounded like she W they were Partners
at one point yes and is that what Miss minutes
was going to convey oh that's a good point that
you guys were does happen you've already gotten
what you wanted in the past or something or in a
different scenario because it it seems like they
were partners and then he he had the whole thing
of like never mind I'm going to wipe your memory
now you're just the main judge you know yeah um
that'd be interesting that'd be that would piss
her off like he you you had power and then it
was taken from you sorry yeah so we've already
this I think they're good ide do at least we've
lived this and you lost yeah cuz she is in a loop
of bringing him back the TV already if there's
a double Loop of like everything you fight for
is for not mhm oh God and dropping her off with
like his decomposing body oh man that was dark
yeah yeah I mean to for my money this is still
the best show like can seeing Loki as a whole
like this is you know what I just realized too of
why I think some of that Quirk didn't work for us
because the show did not change how [__] dark
physically 1800 lights I was like it's still like
shot with this like super dark cinematographer
I did I was looking for like AJ Holmes in the
background like are they going to do a murder in
the background are we going to go to the murder
hotel is the hotel in theory so it didn't quite
compliment the visual aesthetic that to us till
the very end of this to get there but I think
that's what clicked for me the fan I loved it I
couldn't Place why I loved it you're right it was
work it till like 300 or 4 in the morning every
day this week guys so like I have a very delayed
tra of thought on everything okay but yeah that
is the that I think you're right cuz the fan fair
I loved and I was like this is perfect and then
at the end I was like not quite magic here yeah
and that's what it was I wanted to see the magic
yeah felt like we were at disneylander world on
a set and they were playing that music and I was
like I'm uncomfortable like it just felt like
Disney was telling me how to feel yeah yeah but
man nine man a nine yeah man um but yeah guys
uh look um look look listen everyone's got um
everyone's got opinions um I'm GNA I'm sticking
with my my 8.9 um we're all in a very Sim I think
there is just some I do think that at times the
pacing of this like from second episode of this
one there there are some just off things I think
about its pacing that it it it can just like I
don't know how to describe it and and honestly I
got a level with you guys um I don't often like
using this as some excuse I have been very sleep
deprived all week and I do think that sometimes
I can affect like the way I I intake a a certain
kind of Oddity with the with the way something is
paced I'm not I'm not using that as an excuse
to be like actually it's great it's just just
just me it could beat the show itself I I don't
know it's all subjective at the end of the day
can I Lev a conspiracy theory yeah what if maybe
this was intended to be like episode two and then
all this [__] went down and they were like uh
let's let's wait till later in the season to get
to Jonathan Majors let's let's cram something
else in there first let's put moraa in there
cuz it did feel like two was like extended and
put in in a spot yeah it feel like extended and
truncated and and kind of like it could have fit
elsewhere and everything they're saying about Loki
I'm now I'm in the tired uh defend your negative
criticism thing even though I'm like mainly super
positive 8.9 why isn't this an 11 for that weird
Loop in my own head uh you pre the comments yeah
when you work so much on a video you can't you see
like a couple of negative comments that like the
GRE who remains the future killing these C it's
the Lo Loki I think I think everything they've
presented about him is just repetitive from what
they've already done with in season one like even
everything Brian was saying to him in the second
episode I'm like we've already done this uh yeah
and uh same thing with like the little tidbits
here where R vot's like you can't trust that
guy and I'm like that's not really part of the
character Arc uh but at the same time yeah I
I think there's just like we need something
new with with you know how tired Greg is he
just confidently called rapael casselle Brian when
his name is Brad but you said it with such fervor
you're like what name Brian were talking not Brian
definitely Brad hey you're tired like that proves
the tiredness of this man he was like forgot
a white guy name just like H hide my tiredness
all week until this like the last five minutes
of this video I'm I'm really enjoying that on a
time travel show future Greg is like I don't want
to read those comments so if past Greg has to say
some stuff to subvert those comments I'm going
to read later those people already type those
comments and turn off the video before they even
heard I think they have them in a note they just
copy and paste once the video posts they watch
the video they've got their comments planned out
for the whole season they Mad Lib they just mad
lib insults they're like we're going to put it in
here and there's that one guy that's like get koyi
off the channel and he just saves them and puts in
different ad oh my God I saw the funniest funniest
comment about you God my favorite comment um I
think it was on a gen V1 oh no which was uh Coy's
the kind of guy who claps when the plane lands
that is so funny I like that so much clapping I'm
a Clapper I you know I fly too much for that I'm
very we should all be clapping when a plane lands
it's magic magic we just hurdled in a tube through
the sky we just hope we land okay he's got a clap
what a PL lands actually that does serve the way
I see the world we're getting all of this it's
a gift so yeah I'm a clap I'm happy we're here
statistically it's still the safest way to travel
it is statistically Superman guys when I take off
my seat Bel I clap too cuz I made it there I got
there in the car way to travel I'm just like yeah
when I Dismount my bicycle I CL myself I get off
my long board I'm like done did it anytime I'm
roller skating skateboarding any across a major
intersection from Li I'm clapping on the lime
scooter you should see me read a book every flip
man someone wrote that I really enjoyed that page
all righty guys well thank you everyone claps when
that happens anyway we should clap with when we
get to the end of the video see you guys for Pat
the day shout out all right guys well we got to
catch up on some shout outs here because there's
only so many days left in the months we got to
shout out two patrons and we have discovered that
artificial intelligence chat TBT is a brilliant
writer in its own mind so we wanted to bring to
life the fantasy of two patrons that we know if
they met each other in person what it might go
down like during this spooky season season time
definitely so John please pick a couple names
who do you got who do we know who we gotten to
know let's do uh male Lyon and let's do uh Chris
whof all right kale Lyon and Chris whof yeah all
right okay perfect all righty um okay we got this
we're good I got this so I'm gonna say uh I need
you to create a scene of two characters just
want the dialogue a sticker coma if if you will
here's their personalities and have them meeting
each other or catching up while bumping into one
another during trick-or-treating but let's spice
it up really make it intense and and something out
of a horror movie but make sure to incorporate
all these things that I'm going to list about
their personality traits yes of course got to be
comprehensive okay all right so uh Chris Wham off
how how would you describe him selfless individual
selfless individ or just some facts about him he's
been arrested for fighting the good fight yes
yes he he makes good trouble uh he's uh to be
found at a protest sticking up for the little
man likely to be found at a protest sticking up
for the the little man he's a charitable guy uh
charitable individual also a bit of a movie geek
as well you'd hope so being here being here it's
just like a de facto character type uh lives in
the midwest I think for this story you live in
the midwest lives in the midwest yeah and what
are just the things we imagine about him that
maybe we don't know for sure okay like he's a
I think he's a fast runner he's a fast runner uh
slow reader slow reader real ladies has trouble
sleeping gets l like nobody's business yes all
right I love it John I love it okay now male Lyon
M Lyon all right obviously from Sweden Swedish
obvious to break down for them obviously from
Sweden yes absolutely loves James Bond movies um
that's really the only two things we know about
we've been milking that for years he's a classy
guy classy guy um I would say like major Bookworm
major book yeah super into science yes thought
Robert Oppenheimer was correct um sure just
about all the it just yeah about every considered
voting for Donald Trump um these are things that
I just imagine about you m tot even though he
couldn't legally because he's in Sweden he has
a drag Alter Ego yeah drag Alter Ego um consider
Thanos was right yeah yeah oh yeah yeah he sides
with secretly watches every Mel Gibson movie
after post his arrest yes only that period of
Mel and uh and he's a big as riller fan as well
and big aser Miller fan and um often quotes and
recites the Christian Bale rant when out of
words in an argument oh make sure you include
the word rant there so it knows where to Source
this this gold for us Christian Bale Terminator
Salvation onset rant all right let's see let's
see how good of it watch guys we're about to see
magic happen the future is here all right let's
see what it generates okay okay here we go oh my
goodness setting oh let really thinking about
this one a desolate Midwestern Street the last
rays of sunlight disappearing the thick fog
rolling in obscures Vision making the evening
even even more eerie the occasional hoot of an
owl or rustling of leaves is all that breaks the
silence the scene is set for a chilling Halloween
night I'll be Chris all right suddenly bump into a
tall finger catching damn sorry man this fog's
no joke you're all right adjusting his collar
with a slight Swedish accent just do a British
accent I'm fine you should watch where you're
going but then again I lost in uh I'm going to
try it I'm fine you should watch where you're
going but then again I was lost in thought about
oppenheimer's contribution to science a tragic
genius that one huh I'm more fighting for the
hear and now like sticking up for the little
guy genius genius replacing everyone this is
what this with the writer Tri fought against
definitely protests Ries that sort of thing
uh o i Man of Action but even in action one
must know when to speak and when to listen
even at ever hear Christian Bales rant on
set of Terminator Salvation that's me when
I'm at the loss for words I can't say I've
heard it I'm more of a movie geek so I'm not
likely to hear this Christian Bale R nothing
to do with movies so let's so in the celebrity
drama that sounds intense oh it is much like
the intensity of James Bond's missions are you
a fan I've always been drawn to his world I've
seen a few but hey if you want intensity try
running at top speed through the Midwest field
Shields the wind in your face and the thrill
of freedom in your chest who running away or
running towards something sometimes I don't even
know sleep doesn't come easy to me ah the burden
of a Restless mind I often find solace in books
but even then sometimes my thoughts wander like
considering the perspective of someone like Thanos
sounds heavy Thanos huh can't say I agree with him
but hey we have all our controversial opinions
I mean I mean I get quite some attention from
the ladies but it doesn't make me any more
understood ah the age-old struggle I myself
considered voting for Trump once but let's
not delve into politics instead tell me are
you familiar with that Miller's or I can't say
I've seen a lot but Mel Gibson that's a name
been secretly catching up on his stuff post arrest
secrets on Halloween how fitting and speaking of
Secrets let's just say that in some circles not
always known as migale sounds mysterious but hey
we all have our secrets so makes the night like
this even more intriguing the two men with their
differing views and mysterious auras continue
down the foggy Street the atmosphere charged
with the weight of their conversation and the
unknown horrors of Halloween night look these
shout outs might take way longer to do but the
time exponentially yes it is worth every second
this this was ripped out of real life Wow Wow we
have every right to fear and and put precautions
in place yeah now is the time because I could
see a screenwriter taking this material and
adapting it m yeah it's drawing from everywhere
across the internet how can you beat that plus
with directions as clear as these and everything
like it's going to be spitting out scripts in all
time for Vi Chris love you guys [Music]